yeah
looks like somebody has taste the
Mondays
you
quick quick playthrough the epic
high-five animation I'm adding more and
more frames to my animatic so it's
looking more and more like animation not
just storyboards it's more yet to get an
idea what needs more frames its kind of
get a feeling for timing yeah I really
thought I was gonna be like 30 seconds
already but so he was like by seconds
it's slowly coming together but hoping
can get it done by Friday it should be
interesting
I might had a lot of fun with that but
I'm a little nervous I'm hoping they
come suck it hey Dad oh you missed a
spot there
see you guys might notice was a little
white dot in that hololens animation
that we made action gram animation the
way the headset works is a little cursor
right in the center field of view and
you can record just what you see and
have it sent to your computer you also
make specific recordings that don't have
it anyways we messed up and we did the
recording that just captures everything
including your cursor so try to ignore
that white dot just imagine it's a
really tiny dinosaur rocking a new jail
it's close to the GoPro it's physically
possible
how you see the red it is natural
habitat
on weekdays he will do VFX and renders
at the end of his compositing he's so
much rain
she will loathe and disdain on Lucas
when he takes his resting naps
it appears that nature as a one
cycle of life continues it's all your
fault Peter it's all your fault I'm all
your fault everyone in the comments is
correctly guessing that the source of
all of our problems is Peter is that
other thing but in the first video
they'd love to me yeah not anymore
yeah I mean I only touched this in the
computer you know what happens i right
here next year
I do my best clothes what are these
other holes by the way here's another
arrow hole didn't did the tip at all
though just nicely the gopro challenge
where you start with a narrow far from
it and each arrow has to be
consecutively closer to it narrow in the
bottom circle and work my way up
here we go it's pretty close so that's
my first one give myself some distance
it's my second close the distance a
little too much this is my third there's
no way I was going to arrow any closer
to go further than that and it's left
fourth method throw challenge
technically I feel like a cool super
cool probably be asking for a lot of
stuff when Heather gets going so just
helping with concepts and art and all
that kind of stuff yeah I'm so down all
that stuff um the hardest part about
drawing storyboards is strong is drawing
the boxes are square
yeah surprise it it is not as easy they
start off pretty nice and it's nasty for
the Worcester yeah what are you
doing to talk about the movie we don't
know what's going on at this point
number wise budget wise for the effects
just like can you tell us exactly how
many shots we can have can have as many
of you effect shots just went in and
figure out what VFX shots we could cut
think we tried to do so much stuff
practically makes all the difference in
the world talk to them like is this
enough VFX shots what you know you guys
got to figure out things like camera
shakes warp stabilization some
atmosphere stuff like we just add a
overlay and from the camera like does
that count as VFX how many of those can
we do iswe sat down and figured out what
we're going to cut and where and what's
going to change not much is changing
weekly basically we called it a day
without finishing the editing but we
went through and gave notes and stuffs
the editor NASA and I are like stressed
but very very level-headed in Paris
right now here like if there's a problem
you to solve we will solve it
immediately if this world is really
gotta commit to a being real you can't
have commit to a guru and that's my
biggest issue right now how crazy is it
to delay it one more extra week
you